this was a staggering betrayal demisel
it was a betrayal of your directive
as far as i understood it you are
incapable of disloyalty over all else
your fealty to the clionic dynasty is
embedded into your program
hey guys pete here this will be my
breakdown of foundation season 1 episode
7. it's the first episode where they hit
all the major storylines since the
premiere and i think it was better for
it i'll come back to that after i recap
everything that happened but first this
is your spoiler warning if you haven't
watched episode 7 mysteries and martyrs
yet then this video won't be for you and
with that out of the way let's get into
it
we start off with the terminus storyline
at the end of episode six pharah had
gathered up the people she needed to go
after the invictus and we pick up with
them as they're approaching it we get
the story of some of the abandoned
palladium mines that were there where
hugo used to work without the aid of the
empire's tech after the starbridge
attack the industry just broke down and
when pharah accuses him of abandoning
his people he responds that it was more
like there was one less thespin to fight
over the scraps as they approach the
invictus we get a little bit of history
at one time it was the most powerful
weapons platform in the galaxy and it
was indeed a world killer it had
disappeared 700 years ago but it's been
spotted throughout the galaxy since then
never responding to hails and never
being seen in the same place twice
commander doran says that because it's a
jump ship and the empire considers that
tech a state secret they would just as
soon destroy it rather than let the
anacrions get it we find out why they
needed him why they actually needed his
body and it's because of his imperial
nanobots they're there in his
bloodstream they can aid in fast healing
if he's injured and they can also be
used as identification and they know
that they're going to need something
like that because it still has active
defense systems they actually had two
ships destroyed when they tried to
approach it the first time so basically
they have to do a spacewalk in order to
not trip off the alarm system as they're
getting into their suits commander
dolwin tells salvor and hugo that he has
a built-in distress beacon if they can
get access to some form of comms then
they'll be able to send out a distress
signal and the idea comes up that they
might be able to get access at one of
the abandoned mining stations so it's a
big 10 000 meter jump they all make it
except for hugo who says his suit is
malfunctioning as he floats past the
inner ring where everyone else has just
landed i'm not sure if he did this on
purpose based on what they were saying
just before that but it definitely
didn't feel like this was going to be
his death like that was it even though
if it was a plan salvor doesn't know
that so she is actually pretty broken up
about what happened as they're
approaching the airlock they get a
little bit too close together and the
defenses kick in the ship starts
shooting at them commander dorwan is
able to get the airlock open that shuts
down the defenses and as a reward ferret
kills him since he's already served his
purpose at this point they spend some
time exploring and we get some more
world building details at first the
environmental systems are off and they
get those turned back on and we see that
they use artificial gravity of some sort
they notice that in regular intervals
the lights are pulsing and lewis thinks
it might be a countdown when he notices
that they're getting closer together and
we learned that the ship jumped to where
it is now randomly it just showed up
there one day and the current theory is
that it is continuing to jump it's
what's been happening to it the crew
must have lost control at some point and
that's why enacrion had to act fast
because they expect it to jump out again
they need to figure out what's going on
before that happens and it disappears
forever and when they examine the
countdown they realize they have about
four hours until it happens at one point
they encounter an energy barrier and
salvo is able to disable that because
she worked on the fence which is a newer
form of the same kind of technology and
figuring that out means that now they
need her because they're probably gonna
run into more of these and so when they
try to overtake the enacrions when they
try to rebel and get their weapons which
doesn't work out she gets to live and
with that story that's pretty much where
things are left
on the emperor's ship outside of the
salt palace we see that brother day's in
a pretty bad mood after her lima speech
demerizel explains to him that if she
hadn't knelt it would have been a clear
contradiction of her faith and they have
an argument about where her loyalties
lie he points out here that her being a
robot is a secret he says i wonder what
halima would say if she were made aware
that demarzel can't be reincarnated
either and he says that her actions were
a betrayal a betrayal of her directive
as far as he understood it she was
incapable of disloyalty her fealty to
the clionic dynasty should be above all
else that should be embedded into her
programming and she does counter all of
his points explaining that if kneeling
were against her protocols she wouldn't
have been able to do it at all there
just wouldn't have been a way that she
could have physically so there's tension
there i believe as viewers we're
supposed to wonder about her actual
loyalty just in the same way he is but
they're interrupted as one of his aides
comes in to tell him that halima's
speech had struck a chord and she's now
the front-runner to become the next
proxima when they go to talk to her we
get a glimpse of some pilgrims who tried
to walk the spiral or maybe some of them
actually completed it but you see that
they get pretty beat up in the process
we find out that demarzel actually did
it she did it many years ago and that
many people die trying to do it he tries
to bargain with halima he wants to know
what her ask is what she needs to back
off of calling him soulless and
undermining his authority and her answer
is that she wants him to end the genetic
dynasty she says it's not a tactic and
that she really does believe that the
dynasty has to end back on the ship
brother day acknowledges that harry
selden predicted a split with one of the
major religions essentially that
luminism would go against the genetic
dynasty demarzel tries to assert her
loyalty she's ready to play defense and
protect the empire from halimah's
message but dae has a different plan he
plans to prove halima and harry seldom
wrong he goes back to see her and he
declares that he'll appeal to the triple
goddesses themselves he'll walk the
spiral and he'll let them decide what is
true who is right and who is wrong and
that's where his story ends for the
episode and he set up to do that next
time
back at the palace on trantor brother
dawn and azora are escalating their
relationship we see her leave a message
that leads to him finding her for a
rendezvous where they have sex for the
first time she tries to give him a
device that would correct his color
blindness and then he explains why he
would never be able to use that if the
other cleons found out if they noticed
what he was doing then they might notice
all the other ways he's different which
he fires off and there are quite a few
of them to show her just how important
it is that they don't find out he takes
her back to the palace where he shows
her the original klee on the first and
then takes her into this back room we
hadn't seen before
where they keep replacement backups for
all of them just in case something
happens
his reason for existing the reason that
they cloned them in the first place is
for them to be perfect copies of the
original if they can't do that then they
have to be destroyed and their last day
would be their replacements first day
she tries to suggest that he should run
away and she has an answer to every
reason he throws out there that he
thinks it wouldn't work she tries to
tell him about where she lives it's
called the scar the area where the star
bridge fell where the lower levels were
opened up and they can actually see
outside she points out how different it
is in the palace and how everything's
alive and it's waiting for him and she
really tries to sell him on it saying
that they can change his face and they
can drain his nano bots and we'll have
to see how that plays out because i
don't know if any of that will turn out
to be possible or not a little later
whenever he misses the dinner bell
brother dusk comes looking for him where
he makes the excuse that he was trying
to learn about trantor and dusk just
says we are trantor nothing outside the
palace walls is relevant and their story
ends there
and in the final storyline we finally
get back to gail and what's going on
with harry on the raven the harry selden
quantum consciousness protocol which
eventually stops glitching she's able to
talk to him and he comes back and we
find out that he had a data unit
implanted in his brain before they left
trantor and he finds out that they're on
the raven heading to helicon rach was
supposed to be there gail was supposed
to be on terminus to lead the first
foundation and when he finds out that
lewis is in charge he says that that
would be fine to get them through the
settlement stage but they'll need
someone else for what comes next they'll
be facing the first crisis soon which
we've seen that they are in fact facing
she explains why she's there what
happened that rach has been executed and
for a while he starts glitching out
again and when he leaves this time the
life support systems blink out and so
gail's running out of oxygen just before
he returns he says that he owes her an
explanation and that his death was an
essential element to the success of the
plan the foundation needs more than a
man to inspire it it needs a myth that
can endure for centuries and it worked
his death galvanized the foundation and
it's no big deal because he was dying
anyway so he took that as an opportunity
to engineer the narrative alarms start
the sound as they reach the debris field
that surrounds helicon's dark star she
knows where they are it's the why she's
struggling with and she wants to know if
rach knew about everything which he did
harry was gonna take his own life and
rach would stay around to explain why
then a week or so later he would
disappear and they would reunite on the
raven because he fell in love with gayle
harry knew he wouldn't leave her behind
and she gets fed up when she hears this
because he didn't warn her he hasn't
been telling her everything and has been
deciding what she needs to know and it's
pretty rough that he made rach kill him
so that he would have to leave her she
tries to blame him for what happened and
he points out that she's too smart to
play the victim they have a pretty good
back and forth you wanted a different
life than the one mapped out for you and
you made a choice to lie to the emperor
they agree that they're both hypocrites
as she points out if it were really just
about the path that psycho history laid
out harry would have let cleon kill him
in the throne room everything still
would have fallen into place as they
continue to debate who's responsible for
rach's death harry starts to push for an
answer about why she was in his room the
night he died in the first place that
leads into a sequence with her trying to
explain and reminding us of all the
different times she had feelings or knew
something would happen and then she
turns towards the view screen at the
exact moment she needs to to stop a
micro meteor right as it breaches the
ship's hall they realized that harry
couldn't predict that she was going to
be there because whatever gives her this
ability is beyond normal human behavior
she's different and she describes it
saying that she thinks she can feel the
future as the episode comes to an end
overall i think this is one of the
better episodes as i said at the
beginning i do think that it did a much
better job of bouncing back and forth
between the storylines and by including
them all it felt like more happened i
think one place where this show has
really struggled it's keeping up its
momentum they throw out these different
mysteries and different ideas and they
let them dangle for too long so this
seemed a lot more promising the
interiors of the ship look great i mean
they look fantastic i think the expanse
kind of ruined me for scenes with no
gravity because they do those so well
but everything looked okay in that
department here and i did think that the
sequence where pharah shot dorwan was
excellent that actually looked pretty
convincing harry coming back seems okay
in the big picture it's a pretty big
change but it felt like it would be
weird to have him come back like he did
in the books because they would have
been under utilizing jared harris if you
have him you should probably use him
because you see how he elevates scenes
because he's harry selden you can't help
but wonder what's going on with him so i
found myself really engaged with all the
scenes with him and gail and the setup
seems to work for where i think they're
going with it as far as her abilities
and the whole thing about her feeling
the future i hope they don't drag that
out i hope that she gets some
understanding i also really liked how
the focus is starting to shift from the
emperors to demarzo the actor that plays
halima did a great job with that role
her exchanges with lee pacer great he
does a great job of being the emperor
you know that no one would ever talk
back to and she does a great job of
pushing his buttons the whole thing with
hugo was kind of silly they didn't
really sell it as a death and i expect
that we'll see him again next week
considering that they went out of their
way to talk about those abandoned mines
another place where they didn't do a
really great job is that no one knows
that demarzel is a robot considering
that they revealed that she was to us
pretty early on i don't understand why
they have her standing around with their
arms like that and just basically
looking like a robot all the time and i
think that's probably a good place to
leave things let me know in the comments
what you think how you think it's gonna
play out they did release that
featurette with a lot of footage that we
didn't see this week and i made a video
about that yesterday so go ahead and
check that out if you haven't seen it
please like this video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already and thanks for watching
i'll talk to you soon